hello and in this video we'll talk about
omega-6 fatty acid in my earlier video i
have talked about
omega-3 fatty acids so if you haven't
yet watched that video the link is given
in the i button
so omega-6 fatty acids are type of
poly unsaturated fatty acids
which are generally found in vegetable
oils nuts and seeds
so if we talk about the structure and if
we don't talk about a specific molecule
at the first
but there would be multiple unsaturation
right there would be multiple
double bonds in this structure and that
is why
these are generally named as
polyunsaturated fatty acid
and one class of polyunsaturated fatty
acid is omega-6
i'll tell you why they are known as
omega-6 but
before that let me tell you that when
eaten or taken in a moderation
these omega-6 fatty acid could be also
very
useful and it could be protective
for our heart and the
dose the amount consumed is the key
factor
in terms of its physiological outcome in
this video we would learn about
all of these aspects let me tell you
that omega-3s are such as
linolenic acid pentanoic acid or
docosahexaenoic acids
are all having one common structure
a saturation in the third carbon
or in the omega-3 position whereas the
omega-6
fatty acids has saturation in the sixth
carbon so omega-3 fatty acids we have
previously looked in other videos so we
are not going to discuss
much about this but omega-6 fatty acid
has the
unsaturation at its sixth position and
hence the name is given like that
two key omega-6 fatty acids are
rachidonic acid and linolenic acid
both of these are omega-6 fatty acids
now let us talk about the sources from
where we get
omega-6 fatty acids 70 percent of
omega-6 fatty acids are obtained from
vegetable oil such as
sunflower oil canola oil avocado oil
coconut oil etc then 13
of them are from animal sources like
several fish chicken etc
ten percent of them are from trail mix
seeds etc
and seven percent of them comes from dry
fruits
nuts all of these kind of things so now
we have an idea
about the plant and the animal sources
of omega-6 fatty acids
omega-3 fatty acids on the other hand
are generally found from
fish seafood olive oil
etc and omega-3 fatty acids are very
good for
heart reducing inflammation it is
anti-cancerous as well it helps
in preventing joint pains helps in
mood and also during pregnancy
omega-3 ensures proper growth of the
embryo takes place
so all of these are the good side of
omega-3 but what about the omega-6
is omega-6 bad because arachitonic acid
which is a omega-6 fatty acid
is responsible for generating
prostaglandins
and as you know prostaglandins are key
inflammatory mediator
so from our description it looks like
that omega-3 fatty acids are the good
ones and
omega-6 fatty acids are the bad ones
because omega-3 fatty acids
omega-6 fatty acids are generally
pro-inflammatory and they give rise to
inflammation and any other complications
but that's not really true omega-6 fatty
acids
are much better than saturated fatty
acid
for example omega-6 fatty acid which can
be found in sunflower oil
is much better than ghee which is
saturated fatty acid
mostly so omega-6 fatty acids
compared to omega-3 fatty acids there
are differences but omega-6 fatty acids
are also healthy
so in this video what we would learn is
the ratio of
omega 6 versus omega 3 what matters in
our type
the absolute quantity is not really
essential
and this can be understood from
evolution
so four million years ago
the primitive men had a diet which was
having omega-6 is to omega-3 in one is
to one proportion
but as the time progresses now we are at
a situation
where in our diet generally in the
western diet
omega 6 is 2 omega 3 becomes 20 is to 1
so the balance is tipped towards omega 6
and we have we consume our
really little omega 3 in our diet right
so earlier the omega 3 and omega 6 were
balanced
but now the balance is tipped because
now we have more fast foods right and
this is one typical example a balanced
diet which has
more omega-3s than omega-6 is a
mediterranean diet
which is rich in salmon stay salads
all the whole grain foods but in
contrast
western diet is something which has more
omega-6
compared to omega-3 and that's
not really healthy both omega-6 and
omega 3 are necessary
but in an adequate ratio when this ratio
is skewed towards
one side it's not good but it's still
better to have more omega-3 compared to
omega-6
and this ratio is really important
because
if you compare mediterranean countries
such as spain versus
usa you would see there is a significant
increase in debts which are associated
with heart disease
and this can be seen from the data
obtained from wasu's website
that is why omega-6 might have aberrant
consequences
and let's focus on them so omega-6
in short can create or increase the risk
of heart disease
it can evoke inflammation in the body
creating a pro-inflammatory state
it can increase the high blood pressure
we would learn
learn how it can eliminate blood
pressure and other things
can also create vasoconstriction now
let's try to understand
all of these physiological phenomena
from a molecular perspective
so we know that arachidonic acid is a
precursor of prostaglandin
and prostaglandin h synthase is the red
limiting enzyme in this process
and prostaglandin h synthase is actually
augmented by omega 6 fatty acid
whereas omega 3 fatty acid prevents the
activity of prostaglandin age synthesis
and thereby omega-3s
are anti-inflammatory whereas omega-6s
are pro-inflammatory
now arachidonic acid can further
converted
to prostaglandin h2 with the help of
cyclooxygenase
from their prostacyclines or thromboxins
can be generated based on what type of
enzymes
they are encountering thromboxanes
especially
are vasoconstrictors that means they
constrict
the blood vessels and that is why they
are hypertensive agents
that explains why in omega-6 rich diet
there is an increased chances of
blood pressure now
after that these
thromboxanes or enhanced omega 6
products can actually increase the risk
of
heart disease or coronary heart disease
so
arachitonic acid can alternatively
transformed into leukotrienes based on
the
enzyme so the enzyme lipoxygenase
converts
arachidonic acid to leukotriene just
like
thromboxane leukotrienes are also
key mediators of bronchoconstriction or
smooth muscle contractions
so here is a bronchiole and what happens
is
by the action of leukotriene the
bronchioles get more constricted
right which might lead to
several respiratory problems and
one of the leading cause underlying
asthma
could be the enhanced activity of
leukotrienes
so our physiological state
and physiological problems actually
arise
due to our diet then
there are many associated problems if
you have elevated
leukotrienes in your blood level now we
can understand
why we need a balanced diet so moral of
the story
is to take a balanced ratio of omega 6
to omega 3 ideal is to have a one is to
one
so your ideal diet which would be very
good for your health
should be something mimicking the
mediterranean diet that means 50 percent
of that would have
vegetable with vegetables containing
vitamins
minerals and antioxidants 25
of that should be protein which is
enriched
in um omega-3
just like salmon steak which would have
higher omega-3s to omega-6 ratio
and lastly 25 percent of that should
have
whole grains so these are hypothetical
diet plans which
kind of can improve your cardiac health
so i hope this video was useful if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up and don't forget to like share and
subscribe thank you